MARK MIRCHANDANI:
The public sector
has a big responsibility,
and that requires
using the right technology.
Join us in historic
downtown Austin, Texas,
as we talk to SoftServe about
how the public sector has
been adopting the cloud
with Google Cloud Partners.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for joining
us today, Ron.
Can you tell us a little
more about SoftServe?
RONALD ESPINOSA:
Sure, absolutely.
SoftServe is a curious company,
starting about 26 years ago,
founded by some rocket
scientists and their PhD
students, set out to solve
problems in the data world,
complex software
issues, and systems
that just didn't want
to talk and didn't
want to play together.
The company is now
pushing 10,000 people,
spread around close
to 30 delivery centers
across the globe.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So SoftServe
is a Google Cloud Partner.
What does that mean
for companies who
choose to work with SoftServe?
RONALD ESPINOSA: Sure.
Well, it means a few things.
It means that we have
best-in-breed technologies
to work with.
It means that we've got
several certified people
on Google Cloud.
It means that we work
hand in glove with GCP
to be certain that
our clients are
getting the best of both
worlds, not just technology
for technology's sake, but
technology for people's sake,
and making sure that
those pieces of technology
are delivered in concert
with the end goal,
and that end goal is
determined in concert.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: How does this
look for the public sector?
RONALD ESPINOSA: Well,
the public sector
is its own animal,
as we all know.
They have a very
big responsibility.
And the responsibility is
to the lives of the people,
their constituents.
What happens on the roadways?
What happens in the buildings?
What happens in the communities?
And when they look into
technology solutions,
they tend to be limited
because of that lens.
So bringing in somebody
like an outside partner,
like a SoftServe, to
work with technologies
that municipalities know they
need or the public sector
in general knows they need,
or suspects they may need
sometimes, it puts
them in a position
of really being
able to stay focused
on what their mission
is, while outsourcing
to us to be able to come in and
give them really expert advice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's a
really great way to put it.
And one of those examples for
technologies is the cloud.
What does that look
like for SoftServe
to partner with these
public sector entities
and then look at implementing
things in the cloud?
RONALD ESPINOSA: Sure.
So there is the
initial reticence,
the challenges that go with--
it's not mine, it's
not in my four walls,
I don't have a team of
people to manage it.
But shortly behind that
comes the realization
that you really don't
have control over this.
There are employees who are
using their own devices,
that are accessing
personal accounts,
and are doing their
shopping and whatever else.
And so you do have outside
influence on your own network.
But then you get into
the costs of supporting
these massive server farms
that you'd need to support--
connected and autonomous
vehicles, connected devices
to the environment.
There's the scale
that you need to be
able to operate within that.
And so when you start
considering these things,
and you think about your
public sector responsibility
to be frugal while
being responsible,
it makes a lot of sense
to move to the cloud
and really look into
how you can do that.
One of the things
we really like to do
is focus in on assessments
and making sure
that those assessments
result in a plan.
And Google Cloud is very
much in sync with that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, thanks
so much for coming in, Ron,
and telling us about how
SoftServe helps enable
companies, including
the public sector,
to really understand and
do more with their data.
RONALD ESPINOSA: Sure.
I appreciate the opportunity.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks for watching,
and stay tuned as we talk
more about the technology
behind building a smart
city with SoftServe.